hello chess fans welcome to the st.
Louis chess club's stream I'm Isaac
Krantz
I'm Dennis LaRue and today you will be
playing Dennis LaRue Dennis what time
controls would you like today we're
gonna stick to the Blitz nothing faster
than 300 Isaac preferably 5 oh hi I'm
straight this is a little bit slower so
3 out of 5 oh if you feel kind go ahead
and do a do 500 for Dennis
but other than that would we prefer
rated always rated and we're gonna go
down the list in chronological order of
games that meet that criteria so
continuing on words yep I think we're
gonna get started we have a challenge
from senior a board one for some three
oh so good luck ok well this guy's beat
us before he has beat us before I think
I lost to that guy I think that was me
might have been didn't might have been
parry I remember parry playing there
that's not know Dennis LaRue I disagree
I'm pretty sure that's a Dennis LaRue
well it depends on how you define it in
this theory I suppose hello Luke how are
you doing happy to see you again
for those for those of you unfamiliar
with who I am I am the strongest 1400
player at the club yes you were likely
the strongest 1400 player on the company
roster what's the user name it's st.
Louis chess club all spelt out
I hope hopefully Danny has the link to
put them in chats yeah there we go
I'll copy it into YouTube oh just
kidding he's so fast
you can't put your pawn there anymore I
sure can't
you're gonna hang your Bishop I'm
thinking about it no it's the bowl the
plan it's a bold plan this guy can just
go back home okay
just cool calm collected move to peace
didn't hang anything step 1
achieved did yeah I don't think he wants
to do that
I like your move that Knight moves
probably also good for you wanna play g4
maybe do you play the other up to g1
before you play it I don't know I just
like to line all the rooks up at his
King and then push all the pawns made up
oh yeah you know we need to worry about
F for coming though uh okay hold on we
got this you can do it
I'll get straight for that way I'm just
losing stuff already I'm just losing
stuff already nobody noticed Heath
there's no way he'll take it he doesn't
he totally knows him I don't think he
noticed he won't notice that you noticed
yeah it's just things are going bad real
fast here okay less than ideal we drove
yeah we already drove the production
team out of the room there's they watch
this came in ofit we're out we're done
no more of this understandably so I
can't
dan is LaRue yeah dan it's the roof this
cheering help and it doesn't seem to be
helping let's say it helps it doesn't
seem to be helping so far it's okay
we're just warming up looks like someone
racked up some points recently and what
is our rating Oh all the way over 1905
was that Kalin plan did that probably
probably that sounds like Caleb or we
had a grand master plan the other day
what was that could have been that guy
to Boros it was Thursday was Boris
playing for us all right yeah I believe
it was Boris I don't think you can you
can pin a rope to a king yeah let's do
it with this guy not that guy yeah that
guy this mouse is too fancy for you
can't quit yeah handle it you can't
handle the truth it is yeah a little too
sensitive is it too sensitive we can
probably find a way to turn down the
sensitivity but take it back well if
only I can attack the pin piece twice
that won't be so happy but oh yeah might
be something might be a move I've done
the tactics puzzle or two just one good
one at one point yes we're here to give
points back to the community yeah this
is a we're very generous here at the
same less Chess Club he's attacking a
bishop I'm now aware of that fact I mean
let's can we we want to hold the onto
the team as long as possible um let's do
it this way you're attacking another
rook I am I am but seem yeah though that
way it has more tempo
they call me mr. threat maker and then
are your plans rook e1 and F for
something like that and also just not
flagging make him not yeah making moves
not flagging always good step 1
yeah this should be okay
oh no and is broken I'm getting that
cheer him you're in like no Queen a 2 is
coming and I just I'm gonna die I'm so
let's try and mitigate that somehow yeah
you need to is coming was trying to stop
it maybe looking good looking good
you're doing great
you got this and I know it's just not
I've never had more faith in anybody in
my entire life gonna lose we're
definitely gonna Queens attacked thank
you I got you I'm here to help you know
you're doing a great job
no we are the make moves don't hang
anything oh my gosh oh my gosh now we
have stopped playing chess and now we're
just now we're playing who can move
pieces faster John who can move pieces
better who can move pieces faster black
also has the option for better you don't
you you only have the fast option oh
gosh faster faster
more speed we need more power where you
can no take it with the night I'll take
the Queen with the night last turn maybe
you were actually winning for a second
there if you're taking that Queen with
the night were you actually waiting for
a second yeah
yeah was me you might not have been cuz
he has like pawns on both sides of the
board but I don't want Oh might have
actually had a win there for a second
yeah we are an increment why is this
game not over yet no yeah no we're not
you're just playing so fast there's not
used to this level of speed yeah good
game your game board one good game okay
I am defeated that's all right great
warm-up game great warm-up game we're
gonna come into the next one and we're
just gonna we're gonna slug them or
you're gonna get I'm gonna hit him hard
you're gonna hit him real hard how many
oh but we got a lot to get through
you got a lot we have here but I always
start from the top because it's like who
did it and order nicely make sure we
don't skip anybody Hey
well mr. Victor and Gaucho let's go
alright three oh maybe I can
take you alright yeah there was a pretty
funny comeback opportunity there well
yeah you know with with more time I'm
sure Dennis would have found that but
you know he's just trying to don't move
move move
yeah I guess there no I'm here to harass
you and heckle you dude but I felt like
you were supporting me I'm so confused
I don't know what Nimmo I notice you I
don't know but what would a senpai say
back I notice you Sean something okay
yeah this is a discussion for all of us
right yeah I'm not sure um I I noticed
you also ten is all a diminutive suffix
I think they use the T a.m. yeah right
no Isaac time Isaac time [ __ ] also K you
in they also have something like done
Jan Khun chanon
K you in yeah can't you win [ __ ] yeah
yeah I think I've heard caters an anime
is it coming okay you ain't anyone yeah
yeah yeah come I don't know who knows
alright yeah I cross I think it was
parry you beat last time yeah absolutely
yeah the guy do you support communism
generally no right and I don't know if
that's really I well I guess this this
dream is pretty casual we don't we're
not totally restricted to talking about
chess how about we wait and see if
Richard joins us and then then well then
we'll tackle that loaded political
socio-political yeah really come back
yeah but that's really not our
wheelhouse myself or Isaac sorry
yeah teachers an enemy very legitimate
source for knowledge that they are the
epitome of learning things who are some
of the more than some more favorite
teachers the stream audience what are
they they like God yeah what's the
Eraserhead from from my hero como hero
is that what it's called something like
that I mean I'm probably pronouncing it
wrong but
so what world are we in where I'm up
where are you oven to time yeah
something's wrong with something we're
in the twilight zone you'll also
probably just take on on that one square
of where there's a defender of some
other square but let's not say it all
out cuz I cheat when I'm playing Mike
and your brother on the other end cuz
your brother your brother gives good uh
he just knew he's too good this guy's
too strong too strong too good for you
um give me a move Isaac quick I think
you play the boo hoo and you start
tearing up I do nothing then you hope
that you're I don't feel bad for you
I do nothing else and then he just gives
you like a free move or two or something
so sad either if he wants to keep the
Queens on the board he'll take on a few
five what is this madness I agree it is
insanity yeah my man this is sparta if
you yeah are watching this stream for
accurate and even competent chess leave
now but if you want to see what chess
shouldn't be then continue to watch me
stop send him to the gulag yeah yeah
that's where I deserve to be I agree
okay
but we're just playing chess here hey
your rooks on our open files in his iron
well now his this that's the claim that
claim can't wait to make the bishop
Queen battery and then just take on h2
because you'll never see it coming
if the fact that he forked your two
pieces this is not a real fork okay you
don't believe in forks more of a spoon
more of a spoon Cup type of guy have the
spoon fellow myself yeah all right
and be careful spooning leads to forking
I should dream of okay I'm just not
you're fine you're great dude oh no I'm
not young like rainbow I'm just like
crying about my incompetence with a
modern technology no as a mouse or any
of this okay challenge him yeah you're
eventually your nights gonna be better
there's gonna be discovery right yeah
yeah I just wanted to make sure you were
gonna see that do you like you like that
joke bit see thanks I'm glad
well it's Z joke I don't know if I can
repeat it
that's Jer it was a one-time deal can
you recommend any chess games PC or
console with good AI opponents not
really
I've never I do play online yeah of you
I just play the bots on I'm Li chess or
something because you can just play
computers on the mine I don't know if
there's part there's got to be actual
games though that don't require internet
to play majestic chess I hear I hear
majestic chess what redress adventure
what is going on a jesting chess alright
this is great alright I got to look up
majestic chess
so majestic Wow look how majestic that
is that's beautiful that's just exactly
what you want
oh is majestic chess what they have the
VRI over on the Hall of Fame that's
something else
it's just PC from the 90s yes play that
get majestic chats maybe your computer
can still play it maybe it still works
faster it doesn't matter about good just
fast P move anything angry yeah it's
great to move now brunch
another run run so fast faster more
running can you feel the need for speed
oh you might be done for it faster
faster faster get made it faster yeah
only have one movies probably I pre move
mate yeah okay all right good game
Victor Gaucho all right everyone is just
tipsy I don't know if that's a high
enough percentage I would say Dennis
hangs pieces and like half his games
mostly in time trouble though you guys
blender more than suspicious indeed I'm
sure we I'm sure we blunder more than
Eric Hanson when playing Nakamura I take
that as a compliment in fact all right
all right which goes next to you got
next always from the top okay maybe
we'll have a chance against this this
fellow we're gonna play a slightly
slower one all right oh you can handle
this you got this we'll see nice calm
cool collected five oh this is your
wheelhouse right here that's a
wheelhouse what is a wheelhouse I I know
that's where baseball players want to
hit the ball I did not know
well I've just heard baseball announcer
say that was rated in his wheelhouse
when he hit that home run
what is a wheelhouse anybody in Chad you
don't know about an actual wheelhouse is
I don't know a house whether they make
wheels or it's a house shaped like a
wheel is a wheelhouse the like type of
like a generator that has like a big
wheel on a river that's generating power
like that it's out a wheel houses yes
all right cool thanks I'm right
Dennis approves
it's a restaurants a restaurant okay
the production team knows all we know
everything hey look you're like I was
ahead in the last game too so let's not
let's not get excited at all LaRue means
the road in French agree the road the
street what a road straight path
whatever the Rue this is a fact true you
know play night before for 94-96 this
kind of thing yeah yeah oh no no I
wouldn't do it anymore
and also no you cannot so Vic please do
not what is I don't want to know what I
don't want to know I kind of want to
know but I don't want to know okay
greetings to all chess lovers from
Turkey hello hello Turkey hello from
Turkey I kind of want to not ruin that
name but hello thanks to the SLCC for
helping us sharpen our chef's skill yeah
this is the sharpest of chess skills
right here they call Dennis the
sharpener wait a second I guess okay
let's just try not to lose a third game
98 never made so that works right I hate
saying I'm sure yeah that's a great
saying 98 never mate
I believe it wait is that Jonathan no
this is Jonathan's younger brother I
think a younger cooler version of
Jonathan nine months get it right but
I'm like cooler but worse at chess so
take Nick ice I'm so cool usually the
coolest people are the ones saying
they're cool by the way that's how you
know they're cool they're so confident
they could say it now you didn't have a
cool saying about 94 like 94 never more
94 close the door yeah you close that
John 94 you did it
look at that door so close that night
wanted to get in we slam the door right
in his face that's just how we do things
yeah I agree Jonathan and var both rule
they are the best teachers we've ever
had at the club
yeah these games are interesting to say
the least you know what I yeah I make no
I make no claims or promises about even
basic competency at times they all
develop my stuff maybe you'll see me
play again I am an impostor or I don't
hang pieces maybe who is an impostor
good good try Henry McGregor that joke
is too old
is this another non-repeatable joke yes
yep you know guys I want to laugh too I
would like you what do you think about
cricket not a lot I know it's like
baseball but possibly infinite what it's
not all I know it's possibly like
infinite yeah they can go on for a
really long time I see I think that's
like more of an edge case I don't think
that's like a common thing but I don't
know what I'm playing for here I think
white is better not by a whole lot
what's your favorite sport my favorite
to play grow up with soccer
Isaac in rugby I yeah I play a lot of
rugby in college and towards the end of
high school I did uh this is actually my
my Letterman's jacket for running track
in college there in the 400m I'm wearing
my I'm wearing proof that I was an
athlete at one point my life
I ran cross-country in high school if I
can believe it not chess well I was I
was assuming he meant I get answer well
yeah yeah right and also we've had like
long debates with kids Danby is just a
sport yeah what was Caitlyn had a funny
definition which was something like if
you can burn more calories it was
something without burning calories yeah
yeah
yeah so if you can play a chess skate
yeah I don't know it was had something
to do with something to do with the
amount of yeah calories burned anyway I
think you burned a fair amount of
calories playing chess I think like
brain activity burns calories right well
you get tired after a season remember
what I'm talking about I know you were a
part of this discussion no you have no
idea okay European football is the best
I assume rugby is what they're saying I
did I assume they mean what we would
call soccer yes
well now I'm just playing for the C file
I just think it's really funny that what
we don't call the sport that you use
afoot to play a football
we don't well yeah because we're in
America because we're gonna Merkel what
do you want I'll tech I'll check for you
Sanjay Sanjay ROM how long you are on
the line right after this game I don't
want I don't want Dennis to get all
distracted no distract away I'm ahead by
a whole minute and change but this is
five three this may we may just be
playing this game for the whole stream
Eric Hanson burns a lot of calories
hurling chairs okay
barely he gets he gets mad when he loses
sometimes it hurls a chair you want to
not let that Queen get in your face they
can do whatever she wants okay
it is a free country Oh whatever you do
don't take that pawn yeah do you just
run away with your king like a little
coward give up a pawn
but I can't think for myself so I said I
played the first idea I heard okay
Lu thinking's hard yeah I agree us
Americans are dense please forgive them
agreed we're very strong
we're very dense we're a full of muscle
I don't know where yeah that's what he
meant right this is we're very strong
that's what you meant right yeah yeah
yeah how many I guess the big question
today is how many points am I going to
lose on the account what do we wish it I
think that can you stay over 1,800 we're
at 1869
yeah that I wanted ya mean you got a
play oh yeah I thought it was yes 1900
something okay 1906 so our goal is just
I don't know stay above 1800 okay let's
do that what's happening here
um have you ever played football you do
use your feet to run to puns yeah I
played a lot of football in high school
and you do use your feet but the
arguments that you use your foot feet
more in football than you do in soccer
doesn't make any sense to me
you use your so what you got this in
football
I need ears are totally not checkmated
yet I think you have to play off six or
a diet yeah I mean this is extra time so
getting needed this is yeah I'm
embarrassed
is it f6 myself wait you're done alright
now you're done yeah okay good game good
game good game
you can skip casuals if you want but
what was this is mr. casual no that's
rated mrs. Reiter okay let's go Game
four I don't really know where anybody
is in queue I'm sorry bitsy because I
don't know what anybody's name is I
tried to look for anybody that I
recognize but I didn't see Sanjay ROM
and I didn't see bitsy in there Subic I
think I saw you like three or four down
and thank you for thanking us you're
welcome
happy to happen to be streaming for you
thank you for thanking us you're welcome
thank you for thanking us for thanking
you yes and we're so kind here
very wholesome stream very wholesome
Oh big yawn big yawn what yeah I know my
chest is appalling and boring what are
they
what's the stream what's the when
numbers are we know oh that but what are
they look at the chatroom you're talking
about why not kid systems you used to
play the kid I did yeah you want to see
the K ID all right let's go
you used to play it against me a lot and
then I jumped yeah well yeah because I'm
bad at chess and I have a better chance
at surviving and things that in these q
GT q GD type systems that are less less
involved than the Kings Indian stuff
okay that's why as you can see I just
hang stuff without even not even
realizing it half the time
um Isaac what do you do for a living
well I work here at the st. Louis chess
club I edit YouTube videos and whenever
were whenever there's a tournament going
on I'm working on the production team
doing an audio and graphics and such I
certainly do not play chess for a living
I wish I could we have another viewer
from Turkey virtual gruel Istanbul from
Turkey well I yeah I don't know if we're
actually in Istanbul but hello and
welcome thanks for for watching from so
far away you're in for a real treat
Dennis LaRue is a chess player you want
to be watching that's right and then
take c5 yeah that that is not my idea
but sure and why why am i playing just
do it just do it okay his position
crumbles position yeah after this
position falls apart so quickly I don't
know
believe that I may or may not be
facetious I just you know if I've
learned anything about chess here which
is debatable I know how to slam the
pieces harder and I can harder faster
stronger that kind of thing but uh but
is that I love to trade which is
something in brothers hello pervy Sh
happy to have you here welcome to the to
the to our stream love trade it was
better at chess you or your brother my
brother is much better than me I'm gonna
answer that question a million times in
my life no but the better question is
who's better at chess you or Dennis
who's better at chess me or Dennis it's
really close it's like very close
light-years well it depends are we
playing classical or why did I why did
that one get you so bad daddy it's not
that was really funny huh you know is it
the source Bob for me how bad you are
yes
oh but how much better I am than me on
my worst day okay what would what would
what would work less joking more chess
moves less jokes more drawers
do people play chess for a living mostly
just the best ones yeah there's like a
hundred of them there's like maybe no I
don't even think 100 can make a living
from it are 1500 grandmasters um yeah
but they all do there they don't all
make a living off of chess I think
that's the same thing yeah a lot of them
make their living off of teaching chess
it's actually ridiculous how similar
Isaac and Jonathan's voices are yeah
we're very related and a lot of our
inflection and mannerisms are the same
too because we're brothers so if you
don't like one then you just they're
really gonna suffer yeah is Danny really
good he's pretty good he's like 1,900
ish something like that in like 1900 s
USCF not like online blitz which is more
impressive what what are we saying yes
yeah Danny is the worst he's a horrible
chess but you have to defend that poem
for the rest of the game don't tell me
any when you can't defend it with your
bishop so if you can find a way to
attack it with his knight you're just
done oh this is a horrible horrible
experience okay and Mike yeah he'll
never run your King over to that bomb
maybe yeah that is what's gonna happen
but first night out a little bit Alexis
yeah you go back home night oh my god
made him along the H file right with
just my king you can even you can attack
with his pawn twice I can and then I'm
giving up my seat pawn what am i you're
not because he's lied twice that's that
was the point of movie you're king over
there that darn night do they teach
chess or just getting money from
tournaments the really only the very
very best like make a profit from
tournaments there are some tournaments
where like I remember Ben Feingold
telling me stories of he would go to a
tournament and if he placed well enough
he would be able to go out and eat and
if not he would go back to his room and
start teaching lessons but he could eat
the next day
that's something that's uh that's a
spicy meatball you got there Dennis I
don't know it's true do you believe it
takes true he takes back with the pawn
what if you take them back with the pawn
it would have been a bad move but I
agree
all right who's who is what better here
that's a good question
um you got you were down upon for a long
time yeah this is whoa oh now it was
better here what's happening can I save
that guy you just trying to take that
farm oh I want out of my life here it's
hard to know
maybe that's dubious idea but okay well
then I'm too thin like nice would I
rather be here in check but I'm getting
all these checks so you must want to be
me of course
what do you do do you just run your King
to one of the sides either either you
run it to the right or the left well
yeah let's bring them this way to keep
an eye on this guy mister yeah buddy I
think you're gonna be able to capture
that bond I don't know that's true but
why not can you move your rook down one
and then take it or do you not want to
do that for something really don't
because I know that's a better pun today
to eat all these yeah those are better
bonds to be taking maybe you could have
thrown the check in first but that's
just pretty nitpicky no I'll tell ya
yeah I think you're winning yeah go go
go go go go you're the best oh you're
the best to do just know it's so hard to
be you Dennis there's a difficult thing
it's not easy being green humans now you
didn't go to defend like queening square
huh defending the queening square in the
bush good game all right
Oh in 1883 hey you like you're like you
got some points back well done chances
of you going below 1800 have dropped
dramatically everybody did a great job
from talking brothers from the time the
top okay from the top so that's their no
knave BIP see - Oh who's this Ashish
he's always in VAR videos yeah he is
just a student who always comes to all
of ours classes he's pretty good at
tactics he's like I think he just got
over 2,000 USCF yep yep okay you guys
are in for a treat
this is yeah Luke that was a great win
he really did help hold it together
there I did my best it was yeah far from
perfect but uh but yeah it wasn't a
total total tragedy what's happening
yeah I'm supposed to take candy for it
Dennis guide to chess trade all pieces
is black than drunk
that's a except he won yeah well yeah
where you were black masking right I was
I was indeed and what I don't remember
well we well played something like
Queen's Gambit thing yeah it's already
gone out of the memory banks well this
is why I'm bad yeah it was what's
happening on what's going on he'll play
like Bishop g4 or something and I played
this first why Oh he hadn't played 96 I
didn't need to do that anyway
big Batman Begins next please
I'm sorry sir we're just gonna keep
going down the list in order cuz that's
the most fair but I am partial to Batman
why wouldn't I Batman is fun okay
I think see - mmm Queen C - but she's
loose there why not Queen eat you okay
I was just thinking that Bishop takes
pawn takes Queen takes pawn yeah yeah
but and also losing you're like he can
take the the D pawn with his knight
right now no no but no there's a funny
tactic in here all right I can't wait to
see it you ready
Oh maestro tactical genius over here
knows how to do with some tactics you
can't hear it what what do you call it
just a discovery no tactical Magnifico
or a discovered attack or discovered
attack discovered check something with
win the Queen attack so good followed by
the don't get skewered yeah but you do
have an isolated Queen pond so what are
we gotta be careful about that or
positional maestro experts over here so
yeah trade trade trade let's go
you traitor no I you're a trader in
trade or hey Isaac are there any new and
exciting classes member of the club can
attend specifically at 6:30 p.m. tonight
I hear that there are I hear that if
you're on the road
- mm then we get you just the gun just
the class for you if you were anywhere
from zero to two thousand probably
actually a little bit higher oh my god
if you're you know you've done some
tactics you you know some openings you
you know a little bit of strategy but
you're just kind of missing some of the
pieces of what do I need to be focusing
on next come come to class tonight at
6:30 you will be taught by the Lama Lord
the Lord that is of all Lamas where do
Queen go
I lost her it was it was a tragic look
away for once a second I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry I did it you weren't you up way
up on time did I was I was so uh it's
just unfortunate oh no stamp age stamp
age they all do it I'm on the page still
you're like still winning
some of them but like dying on time
faster faster pre move anything anything
anything but that what what's going on
oh yeah this no no it's okay it's
working good job you got the other
pretty move every move till checkmate
good luck or just take us no don't I
wonder if you could take all this stuff
at all good game knave BIP see yeah
that's you've been around my comer men's
of my comfort type ideas strategies this
thing okay so challenges all right we
have one win in five games but I'm not
crying okay I think I see a tear Luke
answered haven't you been talking to
this Luke a sir yeah I do okay he is in
chat like every day and it's he's fun
and friendly good luck sir far as I know
where's guy in box he's he was my
favorite where's guy in box I want him
to be here okay so sensei says [ __ ] he
says he played you in the quad as well
can beat you one time that sounds about
right that sounds about right I'm the
punching bag okay who is it who are you
you're not bad you're just a little
if you don't place c4 you're a coward by
the way well you are your brother's
brother and I defy you both and I say
how do you challenge Dan there's a link
that says maybe I can find it again
get with it that's all you need to know
of that there it is I got it I got this
link
Liam you can challenge us there at that
at that link you can you get you get on
the list by going in there and then and
challenging us on Leach s org what time
format do you prefer this guy prefers
five oh yeah always rated though
pressure is on okay
now I'm probably gonna lose this game
because I broke my triangle but we'll
see Jill is so broken well yeah this is
why yeah production the production booth
was happy and then you know they're sad
what is this production booth you're
talking about Danny yes Danny yes think
about it
my comer is a former champ of the state
of Missouri
he is 1998 scholastic state champion he
is the 19 idea it's classic state
champion I just lost my bishop I did but
now you got this dynamic h-file pressure
yeah yeah with my King right in the
middle yep and your queen on the same
file looks good hey Dennis I believe we
played at Chicago open in 2017 it was a
Sicilian game chest Jack 11 sauce yeah I
play well I had the Sicilian with with
yeah that's what I play was that the
same tournament that you were the mixed
doubles champion I am Thank You Isaac
for reminding me that I am the 2018
mid-america mixed doubles chub yeah yeah
watch out you're Queens attack she is
attacked by the bishop take another pawn
don't tell me what to do so now you're
gonna end up getting three pawns for the
bishop yes yeah yeah consider yourself
ignored just take more bombs let's do it
I don't know why not take them yeah yeah
you got this well you're gonna get his
but don't I get to save my bishop this
way is this not a fear what happens
everything went wrong for your opponent
well he's already did and maybe there's
like stuff maybe there's terrible things
about to happen to you but oh yeah yeah
yeah well first yeah get that guy out of
there please don't hurt me please sir
please
all I know yes nicely now your Queens
attacked
what is happening yeah
closing in school or the other one
that's perfect yeah you're good you're
good are those new employee friends we
have here yeah I'd uh one of those
mooses check check bouncer sees check
that's a police check I'm with it this
pastor saw it who are you calling a me
going Mia Patzer all right well you seem
to be you seem to be going okay yeah but
now I have to like things for myself
don't put it there out something yeah um
don't put it there oh my god it's too
hard I lose I resigned I was thinking c5
okay I love it
she's still yeah our queen does not
she's claustrophobic she wants to be out
in the open
still okay yeah we're up in peace when
you think about that oh my god don't get
that guy off with the second don't get
that guy off the second rank no I said
get him away from me yeah I want to get
this guy away from he said oh god don't
get off now who knows what I'm really
who knows um I don't know what he plans
on doing with this digging all your
palms I found I guess oh stop it you go
all the way to 82 or 87 crazy but I
don't want it also she's she's
decentralized and I'm starting to get
nervous but it looks like she almost
asked you right yeah
and you're Tecna bishop so what happens
now
here and then I guess what are we
thinking that we'll go to a three in the
worse case scenario I was almost
thinking of gone down f7 on my last move
but well let's whoa let's try it again
let's do it yeah I think you just need
to like challenges rook with one of your
Oaks and then if he takes your pawn like
whatever just what about here what am I
supposed to do I don't really know move
tears are to be had you fight for the
center Isaac that's what you do about
material good job you can take that link
take it again that's our file all your
file are the long food are we missed
Queen we missed Queen takes the eight
okay who did you were you miss I blame
it all on you you're so bad at this game
we don't even play that's a mystery that
no one quite knows the answer to
um he's not gonna go for queen king or
queen king how do we do it like that
oh the bishop takes like that our queen
takes the bishop I don't know whatever
yeah your knight hangs no it doesn't
hang you're fine yeah you're sup stuff
so anything forcing is probably good for
you right uh yeah and yeah you need to
trade and I'm just somehow forgetting
this yeah and what do you have checkmate
oh yeah I was just getting this done
this guy's done angry it's not quite
checkmate but but it closed yeah
simplifying a material at least yeah you
look for me to null try not to flag
doesn't don't hang your pawn maybe I
don't know which I want to see though
that see farm doesn't matter who cares I
don't know um you mean this guy yeah
well I think that we have we held
something in Korea
anyway uh moves make moves don't get
made it all good things
making moves not checkmated yet
what to do what's the winning plan from
here Dennis
it's an odd flag step one not flag yeah
alright so far so good
okay we have less than a minute I don't
know it's so good I mean okay I thank
you thank you we just heard a scream
yeah so yeah one thing about being a
1400 player working in a place with two
brackets above you is that you're
constantly appalling and disgusting them
inability to see simple one move mates
Isaac well we saw this art Oh solder a
mile away mile away worry about in there
that's that was the reason you played
the check on f8 was to lure the Bishop
to g7 so that the checkmate would come I
agree yeah we don't need to look at the
net yeah okay more chess more chesco
good game mr. Luke hazard or good game
sir you got to do the rated from the top
he's gotta be rated from the top hey
you're not the boss of me I'm kind of
the boss of you how dare you like
allegedly I have more say in the stream
than you do on this yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay but she used to be my boss kind of
hey this is my little shift manager what
do we are are you doing this yeah oh no
this is everything that chess is
supposed to be you're gonna cry though
when he plays my moves I would jump for
joy jump for joy you didn't play the
moves that I play against you when you
do this when I know he's dying for
totally perfect incorrect chess yeah
you're down to pawns by the way material
is subordinate yeah cereal is
subordinate that's insubordination
what do we do here you're insane
you know you don't do that yeah you do
this first your [ __ ]
Oh easy to her got you yeah no this is
something I should anyway if you played
this opening you should know this but
talk to me seems like a good move
it's the move that seems like it'll be
difficult for him to Castle for us the
game rook checks are in doing very
annoying
who is he blog does he do he's balking
with one of the minors so I have to take
care before this gets annoying but I'm
gonna lose my my pawn I have to though I
think anyway and he'll take care and now
I'm losing or something I'm down upon
you know you played
whatever this gambit is so it's the you
know no one could be losing hello to my
face
Who am I ever see you threaten a knight
fork if you play Knight b5 I'll never
see it coming
you know place Isaac might be five
that's kind of a move like only kind of
Bishop d6 and now my knight is displaced
if you want to have an interesting game
you've got to play Batman Begins he's
almost at the top
yeah we're almost there I think it's
Subic and then Batman next yeah what's
happening
um who knows hard to know all I know is
yeah oh no he was gonna fork me oh my
god what do I do
don't get go forged I don't he's
actually gonna fork you he's gonna go to
d3 green are you some kind of okay
that's me the positional player and
you're mr. mumbles what's with all the
past isn't that my job that just heckle
you okay I thought we were friends
no no that's not your job
Isaac okay just what I was hired here to
do it was part of my job description in
fencing tonight okay where the bishop
maybe you move yeah yeah this is
ridiculous a reactionary you know that
this is a little more sane a little bit
more sane maybe great you know he's
getting greedy might be to was probably
totally correct
um it felt so good to win I don't want
to lose game it felt so good
winning good losing bad yeah you should
do more of the former and less of the
letter
who's gonna take that
I hope I don't care if he does um well I
just wanted to slightly improve my
position if that's even possible at this
point I don't really know you do
whoa oh yeah this is I you got you you
got you good you got something real good
yeah yeah well there we go yeah well is
how I thought he would take with a night
like check and stuff waked up with
checkmate checkmate right yeah
well if he doesn't want to make me I'm
not gonna you're not gonna force it on
him
yeah
Oh silly oh I just okay alright good
good good Guinea who's next
go go go crush crush crush Suva can
Batman Begins yeah you got Subic and
then bet okay then then begins your next
but sue Vic let's go alright what are
you gonna play against me Eve or D for
it would be very careful he's just be
gentle on Dennis alright he's sensitive
the viewers being so rude to you today
Dennis no it's you you're being heard to
me you've got an attitude problem but
it's okay let me just demonstrate how
well adjusted I am okay not a problem
this is not I don't know why I played
that
am I supposed to care of her huh looks
like that come move to me no I had
something is a bishop e7 was not a move
um but anyway but I think this is fine
well this is the air like I used to play
the white side of this um then I stopped
for some reason who knows why we get
into position somewhat similar to this
when I'm playing black against you
[Music]
you know no sure okay I mean when you're
playing your no you never play e6 I
don't know how this would happen in our
game some you always play u5 yeah well
if you play you for yeah but you know
the yellow in a d4 game maybe we get
something like this okay yeah and like
when I play the London I guess yeah yeah
against the London that's where we get
this position in I believe you okay
anyway I'm taking too long
harder better faster stronger all of
those things make you better at chess
yeah you're gonna be to attack that pawn
more times and he can defend it or take
a bishop
maybe that's the like the common theme
that every four-year-old knows about
this opening yeah
you knew this when you were four years
old didn't you yeah I think that's good
I like it well I didn't count how many
attackers and defenders could you count
them for me my jacket my Bishop takes
nasty for you oh my god what do I do
what do I do I don't know what you do
really
you got a yeah you got it you gotta do
this are you sure well what happened it
was long his bishop just blocks it and
he's still threatening our queen he's
not threatening jack except for table
but don't move you're for free he's not
threatening anything don't move it
he's like you're saying there's a threat
all right I agree
the threat was subtle it's hard to
notice but
all right
well I lost a piece what are you gonna
do is there any validity to Queen B - no
cuz Bishop c3 and then I'm a queen c1
track we the other Queen blocks now I
was trying to me nothing doing there
well you could trade down down down up
up down a piece essentially uh-oh
oh that's hilarious okay who doesn't
love playing that's online you're doing
great
well what what did I avoid right now um
let's see
somehow through no fault of mine now
queen bee - looks fantastic because he
can't walk yeah maybe it doesn't look
fantastic because of rook p1 and I'm
just well you can trim and including
pawns you know like on a3 and will be
equal and maybe I won't Fleck maybe or
castle castle dude
okay this is also seen you can do
attack pin pieces maybe I don't know
what's his bishop to his King
you can put your Bishop on that same
diagonal what are you you do some you
did a tactical tactical view of the
other day okay I did a single tactic
what's your what's your all-time high
score on puzzle rush quick tell us now I
think it was a 25 mins to know hey you
got a piece back hey what are you
watching my every move you're like me
yeah I love with me or something yeah I
love you so much oh my gosh you getting
checkmated am i dying
yeah in here yeah come on there's my
queen Oh No tragic okay
throws and counter throws yeah yeah I
was so happy for just a moment okay we
were we had a brief fleeting moment of
joy and then it all came crashing down
this is a sad display I should not be
allowed to play chess okay jack we did
it we checked him
you can do it I believe in you nothing
but positive motivation here
you got this UK yeah you were playing
blog house with Danny and one of my
students yesterday when we were Tamara
what positive yeah just be positive stay
positive positivity positive energy it's
all you need yeah there's nothing else
in the world you need more oh my god
here uh yeah just took on c3 so greedily
and now I'm paying for it
I'm sorry you were paying an amount of
the rice sorry I was wrong I was wrong
to take the night I'm sorry did you see
how he took like five more turns to
trade those rooks it's kind of funny oh
goodness oh yeah check them
Brooke Silva's pin yeah I know you're
absolutely right oh no because the
Rutgers blocks oh if only there was some
way to punish this yeah there isn't
I checked you dude what do you do about
it
I'll never see it well you probably will
see it if he's watching this dream I
think yes
[Music]
maybe I should learn to not do that well
that's like kind of this is something I
have 23 seconds he has a minute let's
focus you got this you can do it I
believe in you wholeheartedly and I
don't believe in myself I believe in you
with all of my being this is getting
weird
you can do this your be pond is scary
yeah that's yeah great move great move
best move I've seen all day dude I made
it somebody doesn't that positivity I'm
so positive
all right don't look good play fast well
yeah there's nothing you can do I
probably guys you could also just resign
and get to the next game so you can get
there more viewers let's go
good game sue they okay you along with
everybody else
I'm stream should we you be more likely
or less likely to resign like less
likely for everybody by watching yeah I
mean if it's Mike playing they want to
see it to the end because they want to
see him do his well that but they want
to see him freak out but also they want
to see him fight for stalemates and
stuff at least I want to see that I
think that's the best part of the stream
yeah thanks for playing Subic it was a
pleasure good game sir good game okay
the way to finish this is to resign I
agree yeah well well said whoever said
that um what's happening here whoa
what's happening here defense tough or
something this is not how this is
normally played
anyway
you want to pawn them yeah I agree
Cormac Colbert what he says you know if
there's an interesting endgame or like a
funny stalemate to fight for probably
good to keep playing but if you're just
down a queen at some point you'd
probably just resent yeah I agree this
is us learning how to be better
streamers yeah we're trying we're trying
we're trying and we have wood to follow
your brother's example we think
everybody for joining us and all that
yeah we love having people on the chat
people watching us if you guys have any
questions for us or about the Chess Club
or about chess in general or don't what
Genesis favorite color is write a letter
just write a letter don't don't ask us
here because we don't know you can send
your faxes to write some number or
something sometimes something fun fact
the number that you call in to the Chess
Club is the same as our fax number
they just disconnected in phases yeah
well I do we really want to be making
this spread who knows it's done give out
that number act I would give it up
number like every tournament
yeah these new streams are a lot of fun
for both the viewers and for us like I
enjoy heckling Denis for an hour and a
half here with with you all well it's
great naturally so because the stronger
the two of us it's pretty close well I
think I know who I'm challenging to the
game of chess this is what the story
even has devolved into my a my coast is
now just gonna challenge me we're gonna
play each other in silence we're just
gonna sit here and then we're gonna eat
each other afterwards do we're gonna
storm out here you're all angry at each
other never I don't know if my heart
possesses the capability Dave it might
not all what are you you're like a saint
or something
yes Saint Isaac that's me anyway okay
I'm getting distracted and you're you
well I think if you challenge me you
have to wait because you're gonna be at
the bottom of the list
okay all right fine no priority fine
you challenged me you have to wait oh we
have a real oh my goodness a real chess
player walking walk away look away look
away you don't want to be here we need
lots of help dude
yeah it's someone you're gonna sub in
for me here yeah go ahead and grab that
chair yeah this is Dennis the Roo plays
the people my name is on the same
alright I've challenged to LM st. Louis
chess club to a game wow this guy was
saying he was better at chess than me
who me yeah you fool as a matter of
belief or just research on you're gonna
I'm gonna take this mic and and point it
at you okay look no you can here anymore
I swear obviously put my head on your
shoulder yeah I mean you know it's were
if you have a tear to shed you can also
cry on my shoulder okay it's my life and
I'll cry if I want to oh yeah van I've
seen worse Caleb you're welcome
are you gonna take that pawn I don't
know why I played 95 I would just take
care for anything you take have fun
you're a man aren't you all this macho
man well you also get made it you know
even made it maybe who's getting made it
first but you don't let's defend against
me just one time just once I don't want
to do that I don't overdo it but very
responsible just once if he threatens to
meet again and no promises I might why
not defend next time it wasn't quite
checkmate but it was spicy
yeah or the devastating check have you
threatened check again maybe just do my
own thing Batman Begins like the worst
of the three you maybe starting a fight
that you not able to finish and not with
me I'm just saying people are pretty
intense about I believe
I'm willing to take a stand here okay
Batman Begins was the that was the first
one right we're like he's he's like a 35
year old playing like a 20 year old yeah
the other ones are better
well maybe he'll defend that somehow pre
move it
okay I'm on the road 22 the road to 2000
I'm on the road to 1450 but that's uh
you got to go in small steps what's
going on here he's got some checks he's
gonna play a check who knows what's
going on here you have a check too
though
what Nighy I don't know about this night
interesting stuff that you're thinking
about I just want to take the night
quick yeah well you're it's defended so
that's why you have to play 96 first to
deflect the bishop I mean I might have
just played Knight g5 in color today but
now I'm just hanging stuff I think that
no just take that let's take that think
9 g5 was more okay well then chief I was
probably like the serious real response
but are you here to like be super
serious I would take its night rather
than g6 cuz Knights are worth more
points now what do I do now maybe now
you take two six you know our captures
Bishop for free and then when the game
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Bishop
seems pretty good pretty good yeah I
know I was I totally thought you were
talking about the dark squared bishop up
until you know you piece I was gonna
catch foil
now you take Queen when you take one of
these is a queen one of his pieces is a
queen by the way oh my god how long is a
queen been hanging like because yeah oh
you're so strong with confidence
everywhere I go it's amazing what we
this guy walks in the room no let me
start crushing how did that happen
I thought we need it was just a little
push it'll push me
you can take that I'm scared I wouldn't
be I think you can pre move checkmate
we did it no no thanks good game like
Caleb did nothing James this was all
Dennis well it's on video yeah those new
things we got maybe what the sweater yo
do I have one of those you're not well
not anymore
you're not allowed anymore yes I am give
it to everybody who works
anybody who like looked at the chess
club get one no no B you're down here
they have a different sweater for you if
you are feeling up to a real challenge
you know they're always buying or you
like all the way down do people want to
see me do the people want to see us play
each other or do they one it's just
Mitch maybe just one okay let's go all
right talking trash go let's go up in
this trip let's go let's go let's go
yeah I don't know no it's all right no
no do whatever you want to do can't
believe you would say that damn dude
what a jerk hey you guys clearly have
some sort of agenda here oh my god no oh
my goodness oh yeah I forgot I did I
always play focus mode on Isaac well I'm
this way on this website at Zen mode
isn't focus mode just calm the website
that shall not be named they were just
there all right
do I Castle or do I just start pushing
h-bonds trying to check made them take
30 seconds to think about it okay
not quite 30 but close enough
what is this nonsense stop
stop he says I say nay I shall continue
the onslaught stopping coming
be prepared winter is coming
stop that what hey you know what a that
type of tactic is called where you put a
piece in the way of your opponent
interference
if you want to learn more about
interference tactics at what time 6:30
p.m. tonight you save for the road - mm
I'll be teaching you all about the
tactical motifs that you need to succeed
on your road I hope that would be
amazing if like the classroom filled up
with like 50 people because everybody
here showed up tonight I thought the
first time I was happening was next week
but that's cool yeah it's happening
tonight two nights
you put a bishop there what happened oh
I'm playing you I forgot I didn't see
the trick gosh I'm so much better than
you at chess probably I'm hanging
something you know the night I could
have saved the night yeah I just got so
greedy for the plot okay well yeah but
my nights hanging so oh no it's not oh
yeah this is for that same tactic and oh
wait take my night on the other two
tickets
yeah that's nice well it just like that
would be a shame if I did right dude did
we just like there was a game three
games ago where I took on a unit Bishop
the a Bishop e7 check and ya defend your
stuff when they attack your stuff may be
dependent defend it sometimes maybe hey
hey hey come on hay is for horses his
horses I where did you hear a dumb
saying like that in horse Ville I think
I say it constantly is the point but
anyway
we're going down time to stop existing
on the chess board I have to stop
existing on the chess board he says I
might have long that all right I mean
who's better
who is better
hard to know go
hey they get now get I'm in I'm in like
Flynn I texture Queen check green check
like it's got out of town definitely
silent any serious well I know you
should yeah you should make fun of us
for waiting so horrible oh my god seems
to be strategy well yeah well I'm the
best who needs Queens alright it's still
unknown who's better find out next time
on Isaac please Dennis good good game
good game good game
you stink all right what did you say sir
LM very suspicious
yes LM is just light chess master they
just give it to people who play on their
site a lot and usually we have good
players will the lesson be on the st.
Louis YouTube page it absolutely will be
coming soon
yep for a week or two it'll probably air
the next time you have the class so
probably next week at the best time
fantastic
you know played b5
[Music]
hey Danny is Atanas playing taro cool so
tomorrow you can see on that schedule
there there's a GM by the 3 p.m. on
Thursday what so our new grand master in
residence Atanas Koloff we playing
tomorrow so if you want to live cool if
I think no way I said yeah he'll be
playing tomorrow so if you want to play
a grandmaster tomorrow on join us at the
same time tomorrow but you might have
slightly less chances at winning it'll
probably be harder to win well oh why
did I play this if the night wasn't on
that six okay I'll just never learn is
always fight next possibly I never learn
I
you don't know me that's the only way I
know how to play against I have best
books for a 1300 tactics books the
answer are is mastering chess strategy
and tactics books sorry for winners you
did it okay hope you disagree ya know
the best book is actually a it's a it's
a lecturer live lecture form it takes
place on went on some Wednesday nights
at 6:30 recognize the patterns that
you're supposed to be learning yeah
that's exactly what if you're just going
through tactics and everyone seems
totally new to you and you're not
solving them because you don't know tell
me more does that happen to you tell me
more all the time all the time how would
I go about improving that Caleb what I
can do for you please introduce you to
these new ideas the chess players use
all the time in their games to win do
they use those on certain types of roads
is there a particular road that they get
think about a specific Road to the mm OH
- mm oh okay the road to mm anyone out
there ever wants to be a mm play you're
gonna need to join this class yes
exactly you in fact cannot make it to mm
without coming to this lecture have not
see this is troublesome I don't know
what to do you're the only mm I know
okay yeah you're the you're the one at
the lecture you got this I know I don't
I'm down upon and with no conversation
for it said I see I just had that you
should be playing on the Queen side not
the Kings side yeah that's true
is somebody telling me this chess jack
did but that was probably a while ago I
think that was in the game the other day
did Caleb just say you're welcome after
a compliment I think so
sounds like Caleb he's known to have
hello
so Dex a two or codec so - I'm not sure
if I pronounced that a or say a talked
about hello beautiful you're welcome for
sharing it with the world
okay okay don't know why anyone would be
confused by that I think you need to be
more passive aggressive more hang
something now okay yeah all right is
there a road to 2001 we don't know that
we haven't yet been there son clear
unclear that is in fact the road less
traveled that they're talking about not
make guarantees on that one hello Tariq
it's good to see you again
yeah I can't think of real ideas Caleb
some threats we're doing this you please
check first I don't know I don't does it
matter
yeah well I might not get the chance
that sound made me think know something
about that sound just said nope don't do
it okay okay what does compensation mean
well it's it's mostly just like you have
some advantage on the board for losing
some material it's a positional
advantage for my losing for a material
disadvantage so sometimes people like
lots of gambits have compensation where
you give up upon and your compensation
is peace development or an attack or
something well said I say okay
so the main point kind of behind the
Queens gambit declined or I accepted I
mean accept it oh good game all right
it was fine I was a mouse lit all right
well this mouse to sensitive man no I
think dennis is too sensitive
will you stop attacking me last one for
me know how Danny your you about to call
this a day or you might plate one more
we're gonna keep going play until you
are on the brink of losing your sanity
[Music]
okay radiate 500 sir yes let's go oh
I've lost to this guy before to see me
play like this for some reason I don't
know why but because
I don't know it seems fine but usually
the bishop doesn't go there right I put
that Bishop there sometimes can you just
serenade me can I actually just have a
recording of your voice to fall asleep
to at night
yeah that's what I really need that's
what I really need because I have
trouble sleeping lately I've been
listening to day nine play Magic the
Gathering as I fall asleep loser says
what we used to have people are gonna
get the wrong idea
I'll try and convince him to play you de
Haan okay yeah we'll see I'm all about
playing all like all I can promises is
to try yeah well I'm sure there's a lot
of players are like oh this is the
easiest guy on the stream let's play
this let's get let's get these rating
points while I can are you still over
1,800 yeah you're doing great dude
you've only lost like how two points of
it I don't know what this whole thing I
did with my cleaner right now is but
let's just pretend like guy dude it
makes as much sense as anything could
ever make yeah I should have just taken
him play Bishop f5 right yeah no oh no
the Queen was pinned I can't read things
okay okay now I'm Bishop f5 tell me is
Bishop f5 on the road to mm yeah I know
I mean was the question he doesn't
really want to be there and I want to
play f5 but how can I resist his queen
is on C to give me a real move somebody
kick before you dude all right
look that piece is off the back rank
great job
you don't win anything but it's good is
there the the night not not even 194
yeah cuz that bishops annoying you and
now it'll it'll annoy you less when it's
gone you might play Richard III and then
then the real the real things can begin
do you think he's not wouldn't you take
enough or take or anything
III was optimistic I don't think it was
gonna all right now we don't want to
lose that pond which fun your be pond oh
do we care I mean I don't know you told
me man I say no I want to play you for
and keep the night stuck in a bad place
forever he'll take there I'll play rugby
eight and scare my way there's all these
all like crazy fantasies or maybe we
just play regular and how many hours a
day twelve
I mean more the better but it's more
important to do it every day than to do
like a lot on one day and then on the
next day so if you do so many in one day
that you get tired of doing puzzles and
you don't do him the next day then you
did too many pauses see he was clearly
listening to us because now he's like
these guys are never gonna play for so
it's better to do like five minutes
every day than it is to do an hour one
day a week leave me alone dude do
puzzles all day every day
I agree uncle of manual is this strange
oh yeah yeah yeah I agree but I never
work empty one and one
get out get out of there you were not
invited
nobody welcomed you here please leave
terrible guests dude just comes over and
tries to take all your pawns
well you trade everything and leave them
on the seventh rank we're exactly where
he wants to be or we find some other
then do you just you just trade
everything and then walk your King over
until he has to leave the second ranked
seventh do nothing he does also have
like no threats so like do we have
anything better that we want to do maybe
be six me know maybe six is not this way
or this way hard to know he's coming one
way well we got to pick something bring
him closer to the middle great job hello
there White Fang well I believe I've
seen that name before in chat have I
read that book - yeah yeah he wrote call
of the wild - yeah I read what you guys
are the worst London his check London is
Jack London I said Jack did me oh yeah
a White Fang it was like it was a like a
fighting dog or something he got trapped
in a fighting ring and then escaped
no that was does that call them one [ __ ]
I think that was called a while though
suck okay I was called a while white
thing was the wolf but it was like
fourth grade reading I'm Rio so I had to
read this thing I don't think it was
required of me I think I do
I think there was just a like a book
fair at school in 4th ish grade and then
I I liked wolves yeah I think that was
about really cool things you're on the
good did it certainly did that wolf was
very white and full of fangs who wrote
Red Badge of Courage though is that also
it might be on the chat I think you now
all you kind of want to start trading
things there because eventually you'll
play rook d8 and something will be
pinned maybe higher rated player yeah
that's cool that's a great opinion oh
there was a point there was what is it
the point he got you did it his next
trick he's gonna play something there
Felix Omar asks the real questions why
watch this what okay geez so what's your
rating Felix is the reason you watch
this is to take free rating points from
from me yeah yeah nice very white and
full of fangs yes
can you guys livestream lectures we've
thought about it there is likely going
to be some sort of entertainment or
educational content entering these
streams Jonathon want to do it because
he had a series on the Dutch that never
quite got finished on YouTube because he
stopped doing lectures but he might do
it on stream and then there's there's
all kinds of things that we're trying to
do like we might eventually start
streaming late at night and have like
educational content during the day and
then fun stuff at night ladies night 30
January 31st at 8:00 p.m. that will be
purely educational content that's Anna's
doing that I think Emily is doing it
evie they're doing stats hilarious
that's cool
all right what's your time he says cram
e Thomas who is the lad on the couch I
assume they're talking about this guy
it's just a chair it's just a chair and
he is the Lama Lord this is or you could
call me by my human name no I don't know
you as a human being dude I know you as
a chess-playing Lama okay well hey
that's good that was amazing gonna play
Queen takes Queen why watch this as one
of our chats for moments like that
that's why you watch this thank you good
game sir Knicks game who's next - on
slate I don't know
always fight this guy he was in chat and
he was in chat and said play me please
always fight yeah like I'm only rated
always fight only rated and you're only
nearly everything maybe one more game or
something bomb this please do in depth
on Evans gambit well this is the guy
no there's no what you play is that what
you played Evans gambit what give it to
you for it as the more a gambit in the
Dana Danish gambit the way you seal
that's what I see all the time
you're on Twitch right now you're only
human off stream agreed
you are now llama yeah alright who oh I
guess we're playing this yeah yeah I
want to play the lower rated guy but I
think you guys will play this guy he's
too strong
see and just play the French no matter
what they do right you did a rated dejan
if you made a new one then it's rated
maybe he'll play you next yes I promise
he promises in fact yeah yeah this is
the stream that never ends well yeah we
don't want was on Danny to go crazy
zones the minnow just whatever do it for
play forever I'm not I'm not harassing
you
oh yeah well okay you just take my voice
as signs of harassment because I harass
you so no it's not that I'm more
concerned with Danny sensei but it's
alright I don't care about you Isaac I
play chess a lot what time control can
we challenge you like 500 Rea did but
it's unlikely that you get played now
because they're probably only gonna play
one or two more games yeah what time is
it where am i it's 4:33
okay hey thanks dejan it is a great song
especially when I sing it because I'm
the best okay I'm with it all right
let's play some moves it doesn't really
make sense
sure is a move I don't sense any sarcasm
enormous well not an ounce okay who yeah
maybe you double rooks sure why not I
can't say for sure
well now where does my knight go
everything's oh I know he sees he sees
my plan to have anything else well it
would talk to me no oh for but it's like
well if I don't sound like the same
thing did he play you are making her
yeah I'm not having fun anymore that's
true I'm okay just 95 it's fine just
just pass until he makes a mistake yeah
it's just so what does reversed mean in
openings such as reversed Mexican
defense bill never heard of give it to
this guy he'll do it colors suji's and
different so this is a lot like reversed
peroxy binds but not quite as black
spawn is on e6 so with the white pieces
white would put pawns on c4 and efore
and try prevent black from playing d5
but in this case black is trying to
commit from playing d4 so it's reversed
the colors have been reversed deep
anyway
he hasn't made a mistake yet we got a
we're still waiting for that well yeah
I'm I should have been punished for this
whole Bishop it may be seven play mixer
context or it takes won't you
eventually he's gonna move this bish up
in there shouldn't play checkmate right
that's what I'm waiting for
well yeah we can I'm just waiting to
shout checkmate yeah I'm sorry I meant
Vey it is it is probably unlikely that
you end up getting played because we
just don't have a lot of time left this
seems to be the case
speaking of not having a lot of time
left okay down almost two minutes Oh
super yikes oh gosh so much I really win
this game I agree
oh well I don't know what I'm planning
deep just I don't know what you're
planning is nobody knows are you
streaming on Twitch right now as well oh
yes we are on this guy is just to steer
on both of the things okay that's our
that's our twitch stream YouTube chat
I'm gonna do the opposite to certain
games yeah it's just
hey that's our YouTube streams time we
making a mistake II what is really do
you really just say we make a mistake I
sure did yeah on the bond oh you did on
the pawn did hung upon and well done
hello darkness of the skies faster I
ain't gonna die there's a d5
we tried good fight good fight okay
there's one there was one person you
have to be still have left to play
eight challenges okay catch it was a
rated game always fight always fight
yeah yeah we've been there dancing on
here II challenged us to a rated game
he's been here forever
thankfully here you go good job why
would you challenge me to play III cuz
it's the bravest of moves okay you know
we know we have to know this guy yeah
he's doing the cloud of something some
sort of cloud yeah I wouldn't even I
don't even know what it means all right
let's go word to be a clone of a
specific claim I wouldn't understand all
I know is I am enraged how dare he play
this against the absurdity ya know I'm
impressed and we must know this guy
that's always fight for all the internet
kids are doing that these days I see I
don't care about
I'm just care that I'm ahead and million
tempos right no you guys are good night
Robert Lamm sleep tight
it's just pretty much the end of the
stream anyways so you know you're not
missing much just just the end of this
awesome game yeah you have a wonderful
evening thanks for joining us we had so
much fun
you're not allowed to end until you win
I've won a game or two so and on this
dream some party let's see if I don't
use death let's see if already I think
the cap guy can obliterate them whose
recap guy yeah yeah you're the cap girl
is because they were making fun of my
lack of a haircut last time maybe all
you needed was a comb and perhaps I am
we're proud of you de Haan doing it for
the boys we needed one of these two this
how dare you stop making this fine but
say everything is totally cool 94
he can't cast cams castle Oh cuz he oh
yeah he cuz he did some King stuff where
is Danny Machuca he's over there he's a
little bit that way who is Danny Machuca
who is Danny Huachuca what I only know a
shady tech guy shady tech guy hmm
yeah we're happy to have you White Fang
thanks for letting us talk about wolf
books
check them give up you know I think that
book literally ended with him going to a
peaceful farm in the country yep I think
so okay yeah Queens yeah yeah oh look at
me dude I'm good
that's what I wanted to play it's why I
sent it I wasn't saying cuz I'm so smart
I'm just saying it cuz that's the move I
wanted the internet saw dude draw at
best against the world the world's
strongest 14 you read the world's
strongest fourteen hundred and you are
the 2018 Mid America good you look
alarmed like that really scared you okay
yeah see Caleb you probably just want to
take it is LM a title it's not a we are
so good title it is a why Chessmaster
title it just means you're a content
creator on my chest that it's somewhat
decent we mostly got the title because
we we just stream a lot on lee juck's
know why Joselito
probably don't want to trade yeah yeah I
agree so here d5
yeah the defend your pawn tank his pawn
- you're on the CFL first cuz you can't
castle so you just win basically as its
challenged how that works
it sounds true enough to me Brooks
Brooks e4 and so like c4 you could also
go to c2
always fight he's fighting
when will Rex Sinquefield play the
people Roman probably never ate I assume
that'll never happen
hey okay I can I can count and I know
the screams sometimes you're the best
yeah yeah looks pretty good I hope
Taylor was Mike isn't tasty like I'm
just leaning back and casually does
nobody actually can hear Caleb CK let me
I'll block Caleb nobody's not even here
oh we three wins I knew it all along
when I act except I don't understand it
until I figure out things anyway you got
this
you can't take cuz you made them Wow
you're - yeah he can play a check and
you can block it all the stuff seems
good for you
hey who's playing the staff tournament
tomorrow me oh right that's tomorrow you
win it last time I did got a defend the
title is loser is the evil version of
Caleb all right what is I played the
move I found it on my own so of course I
know that the natural follow-up is
checkmate yeah looks like it's placing
meatball okay do you like meatballs
spicy ones they're pretty good they're
pretty tasty dude you trying tell me you
don't like meatballs no you're not lucky
he got this far with that opening I
agree Queenie - okay just animate Queen
behave this is this is a very common
system Emily just took your GM title
back yeah we had GM streaming for a
little while so we did have GM but we
don't always have a GM playing so we got
we got the LM title
it's a good substitute well it's a step
up as Jonathan says it's a promotion so
it is we got promoted to upgrade he goes
and motivates om we got it again an
upgrade that is spaghett so he did it
with spaghetti did you didn't want to
get Rick mated well I you still might
check my time soon he has a defense will
he find it whydid been Feingold Lee
didn't find it he had to play it he just
started his own Chess Club
he said I'm tired of working for people
I want to work for myself and maybe the
games Club in Atlanta always fight good
good job and it looks like Danny is
cueing us up all right well that has
been our dream today thank you very much
for joining us thank you be sure to
check out and be sure to check out to
2,000 talk by me Caleb Denby USCF expert
extraordinaire it's night at 6:30 if
you're in st. Louis come down to the
club I'll be sure to check it out if not
check it out on the YouTube channel yeah
bi next week yep should be up next week
thank you very much until next time
goodbye
good night